it's ten o'clock hello everyone I
welcome another edition of our link
gathering they're waiting for Steve to
appear I guess but otherwise hi Eric
hi Gary hello nice background area
someone has the YouTube or stream Erika
ja think one of us unless it's me
oh sorry I thought you did that but I
guess I hadn't hang on one second I just
got to get this Steve is having trouble
getting our the right zoom link here and
maybe JA in the meantime you can update
our things going here in the lockdown
okay good yeah
do you want me to just go ahead and
present them oh sure why don't you do
that yeah why don't we start in today I
just thought that today we're gonna talk
a bit more about the mobile app because
in math gatherings we've we've shown and
not just us but other participants have
shown the web app but we haven't shown
the mobile app so I think we're set up I
think at least I I've set up I think I'm
gonna be able to show the mobile app I
don't know about hopefully you guys
maybe can - Steve I don't know if you
will but we can at least talk about how
we use the mobile app and and and show
show it today for everybody so you can
see that so John maybe you can lead us
off sure so hi everyone I'm John train I
have pop the link team I'm currently
studying French and actually I make a
video every week also on the link
YouTube channel and if you haven't
subscribed you should if you're learning
French I give some great recommendations
for resources I just show what I've been
up to in the week how I'm using like
that kind of thing so yeah I've been
studying French probably in a really
dedicated way every single day without
fail since the end of December and the
goal as you'll see in the videos in
academics channel is to be speaking by
the end of the year so whatever that
means for me I'm not saying I'm going to
be fluent whatever that means but
definitely able to hold my own in a kind
of a basic conversation and I've
definitely found that for me there are
dips in motivation and desire to even
study and when I hit a dip which I kind
of have this week I've just been a
little unmotivated I add something new
to the whole journey so for me something
I've been finding quite fun to do is to
get a French recipe create a lesson with
it on link and then study it and then
actually make the recipe and I challenge
myself I try to make the recipe just by
reading the French instructions and not
looking up any English so it could go
terribly wrong but so so I just wanted
to show and I'll just share my screen a
second here I wanted to show the site
that I use for French recipes and how I
import lesson using the iOS app can you
see my screen yep we can see it can you
see my phone yes okay so the website
that I've been using is called the
languages kitchen so this is great there
are French and Italian recipes I believe
yeah I think it's French and Italian
obviously I'm just interested in the
French and so I think I've only tried
one recipe but it's great the page is in
English and French and so when I'm
creating the lesson on the web I just
copy paste and take point to the English
but on iphone i would just i usually
just import the lesson and then there'll
be a little english in the lesson but i
just ignore
and I made a bus nice horse
[Music]
so yeah I will grab the lesson about the
recipe and like I said I'll link it
maybe two or three times because if I'm
going to just use the French to actually
make the recipe I want to make sure that
I know how to say this website has
numbers for grams of butter or whether
in noodles so what I like to do is go
into on the web and change them to a
word because so that's just an adage
well it's looking the numbers but this
definitely for me anyway that's
something I have to memorize so there
isn't you can see some of the English
there I've actually treated to the
lesson of this before so it's pretty
easy to do so boom and then you go into
the French so I've been finding this
really helpful to get me motivated to
ganon so studying defining that I'm a
bit of a long dip in motivation
otherwise as you can see you make what's
that make that tart I haven't made the
sauce I made some chocolate truffles I
thought stop easy because I don't want
to mess it up I made like it was fairly
cooking
there's bowls of chocolate but they were
good I want to make this top it looks
really good I love desserts I'm looking
forward to when the lock down is over
our work from home and I'm coming in to
eat your pastry once a week here
what's Wow okay but yeah pot for a lot I
I tried to do a Steve says do what you
enjoy and then the line to join in it
seemed like but sure you're just finding
information through the language so I
love TV and movies this into the night
is the most recent Netflix show that I'm
watching it's it's a great one it is
science fiction the Sun is killing
everyone and this one group of people
fly around the planet I'm trying to get
away from the Sun that sounds bizarre it
is it's fun and I try to read all of my
coronavirus news now in French so I
allow myself to to three news stories
just before bed and so yeah I get all my
coded my to news in French that's great
but yeah that's basically what I'm doing
a lot of a lot of movies TV shows
Netflix shows Lamont is another great
one if you're looking for French shows
I usually just search French I will
usually just search for French TV show
know French movie on Netflix and then
Rotten Tomatoes the show because I find
that that they're really good ratings
usually so this movie if anyone's
looking for an excellent movie I did
wanna mention this is fortunately those
room few on foot is one of the best
movies I've seen many this just happens
to be a French movie Nikki came out last
year the fly out anyone is studying
French I'm looking for a movie to watch
it's set in the 18th century and it's a
love story I mean even if that didn't
really seem like my cup of tea
ISA but I am so glad I wash
such a beautiful beautiful film and the
French kiss would just slow
there's think many slimy because it's
old so it's perfect for French trainers
- yeah that's what I've been up to and
yet just to remind you guys that you I'm
not subscribed to the link YouTube
channel whose do um Eric who's also no
speak is updating on his Japanese Jimmy
as well and I I'm creating videos about
my social enjoyment great we have a
question here Jerry
Doreen what happens to your app if you
change the language in your phone uh and
I we get questions like this quite often
related to changing your language on the
phone because it it is there are a few
different places to change languages one
language I mean uh there's there's a
place to change I believe there's a
place to change your interface language
on your phone which will change the menu
and everything I don't know if you do
that I did I had it in French
something was oh yeah so all of my news
was then in French but and this was a
while ago and so I I couldn't read
enough of the headlines I was finding it
quite frustrating I just wanted to check
the headlines and like I understand any
of this so that's why I changed it back
but I was very gung-ho about doing that
at one point I'll change it change it
back actually to French that's a but
then also there's just under settings
there's reader settings and you can
change your dictionary language and
there I believe in that that way you
know some people sometimes have the
wrong getting translations in the wrong
language so if you would like your
translations in a different language
then you can change your dictionary
language the dictionary language setting
which I believe is in the reader
settings so hopefully that answers that
that question there
there let's see the QA guys think I
could not create a playlist on my moto
Zed to force any suggestions playlists
every completed lesson is automatically
added to your playlist there's one
playlist for every user has just one
playlist as well in the menu for any
lesson you can tap on the menu like the
three-dot menu and there should be an
option to add that lesson to a playlist
or if you're looking at a list of your
lessons like in my lessons and you tap
and hold the lesson you should have an
option to add it to the playlist but in
general if you complete a lesson it's
added to your playlist automatically so
that's the best way or easiest way of
adding lessons the other thing I know
that and maybe Steve will talk about
this is playing courses but I'll leave
that for now yeah maybe we'll just
continue then with Eric maybe you can
share how you use the app and we'll kind
of just go through maybe all of our
presentations and then start to deal
with most of the questions at the end
sure so I'm just gonna share my phone
screen right now we'll see if this works
yeah
okay there it is
now I just need to share my screen on
the zoom share screen okay
yeah you can see my screen now yep okay
let me see why my phone disconnected let
me try this one more time connecting
ha qualia connected oh no but um so I've
been doing lot of listening lit recently
I find that I listen to
in Japanese I listen to the same content
like three or four times in a row just
so I can pick up new words in vocabulary
so that helps quite a bit also I'm doing
I'm reading my first manga which is a
great goal to have and I'm reading it
and I'm almost actually finished and
what's great is that all of all the
reading I've done on the link has
actually helped me pick up the manga
vocabulary you hear in the faster so so
I'm just trying to figure out why this
is not working out but um ya know I'd be
reading on link for the last year and a
half in Japanese and I phone my phone
have you just having difficulties right
as we're doing this maybe mark I can I
will need like a second to tell us up
there yeah mark mark good I asked just
as we're sort of parading our lack of
skill and handling all this technology I
thought I would offer myself as a
further example so I've plugged my iPad
into my computer yeah and sort of it
shows up here in you know in finder
sometimes it shows up sometimes it
doesn't when it does show up I go trust
and then it says I'm supposed to trust
it on my iPad I can't find any place to
trust it on my iPad I can't seem to make
a connection so I got several things I
can do I can forget about it I think it
why just to maybe talk about how you use
it a or unplug your iPad and plug it
back in again and then it's okay I just
thought I would get Varick a break while
he's eating through technical
difficulties just to show you of my
technical difficulties but yeah I will
talk about how I use my iPad
phone and what do you call it
pod whatever call it any pod or
something I'll show you all of that
later okay why don't you go now okay so
all right so since I'm where are we now
let's where's my stupid thing did I get
out of zoom are you can you hear me yes
you you see that's the thing about all
of this technology where I resumed ah
here we are okay no all right so mobile
so we're talking mobile so obviously you
can essentially do much of what you do
on the web you can do on your iPhone or
on your mobile device iPad I my go-to
device is my iPad you know this guy here
because I prefer the larger screen if
I'm sitting at home I want to link I do
it in the iPad I can also if I'm going
through Twitter and I see an article in
check for example like I tend not to my
main language is being Arabic and
Persian I would don't yet happily go off
to a newspaper article in those
languages because it's a bit too
difficult but languages that I have done
before I will sometimes see an article
that's interesting use the browser
extension and import it directly into my
iPad but in terms of my routine I would
say that I use all three devices the
iPod Touch okay and I just have a case
here but my iPhone and I use them in
different ways and of course I use them
in combination with my air pots so all
of these things are part of making my
language learning very mobile so
typically in the morning I get up and
the iPod Touch is the smallest and yet
it's it's large enough that I can
control things on it I can I can connect
to any podcast that I'm following so
it's quite a powerful little device but
I carry it around with me I don't like
carrying my phone if I'm vacuuming
around the house or if I go for a run
then I'm gonna take this guy and it's so
this does all the same things but it's
just more mobile and because a big part
of my learning is listening but I'd like
to do as I go in to the course that I'm
using so again just by the way I decided
to go after eleventeen Arabic but I got
sidetracked because my wife started
watching an Egyptian Arabic series on
Netflix so then I went in and I found
some Egyptian Arabic in link and so I've
been listening to Egyptian Arabic so I
get up in the morning I listen to
Egyptian Arabic at some point in the day
I have to go either on my iPhone because
I find this screen too small typically
on my iPad you go over those lessons and
pick up those words my hope is that
tonight when we watch this Egyptian
series on Netflix I'll understand more
than I did last night
so the whole thing is about mobility and
so essentially even the smallest unit
has all of the material and as Mark said
I find it I tend to stay on one course
at a time and I tend to go lesson one
two three four five six back to lesson
one so I like the listen to course audio
feature so I don't have to move anything
to my playlist I don't have to reshuffle
my playlist or take stuff out of my
playlist it's always there if I want to
listen to this course I go there listen
to course audio and then I don't have to
do anything it'll be if I go for a
thirty minute run and the lessons are
all five minutes long I will hear six
lessons one right after the other so I
find that very useful insofar as
listening is concerned but insofar as
actual linking I find the iPad is the
most convenient place for me to listen
to link because it's large enough
whereas the web browser for me I have to
sit there in front of the screen I find
that a little more awkward so that's it
and the iPhone is it has the advantage
that if I'm out I'm in a doctor's office
or something waiting somewhere my iPad
is not 3G enabled my iPhone is the
screen is smaller than the iPad but it's
bigger than the iPhone what is it called
Apple what is it called again
iPod Touch I use this thing so I'm
mobile and
I often remind myself that in terms of
the range of material that I have in my
iPhone or iPod Touch I have more
material in a greater variety of
languages than a language lab that you
know universities used to put in that 50
thousand or a hundred thousand dollars I
carry it all around with me in these
three mobile device mobile devices and
of course for that matter when I get in
my car whereas normally I'm connected
Bluetooth to my airports in my car I'm
connected Bluetooth to my car radio and
so I can listen to it there so total
mobility but I can't plug it into the
computer and show you what I do because
I'm a little bit inept technically thank
you all right that's good and maybe
maybe I'll continue then and I'll show
some of the some of the functionality
that that you're talking about let me
see if I can now share my screen next
trick let's see yeah and your phone okay
so yeah this is this is obviously my
lesson feed in Japanese one of the
things that I study like like Gyrene is
I try to read some of my coronavirus
news in Japanese I don't read all of it
in Japanese I end up reading a fair bit
of it in English to Italian for that
matter japanese is even trickier than
french because if you haven't seen the
words before it's even if you know them
you you have trouble understanding the
the headlines but I can see that this at
least is related to Corona I don't
really know what the title is but you
know yeah so in your lesson feed and
it's not always clear to everybody but
in your lesson feed you see lessons that
other users are liking but you also see
lessons from import sources and so this
particular one is from I don't even know
what that is to be honest but you know
what's up I saw a digital I saw he
digital okay so it opens up that article
in our built-in browser and then if I
want to import it I top this import
button in the top right corner and that
lesson now gets imported into link so
just to make that distinction that
actually in the feed there are some
lessons that are in our library and
others that are going to be imported the
imported ones don't have don't come with
audio obviously once the lessons open
we've we've seen how how we all know how
to create links and so on
maybe I should point out that here
opened this menu on the right and this
is where you'll see there isn't oh no I
if there if if this had audio this is
where I would see a button to add it to
my playlist but this is obviously
imported so that doesn't exist a couple
things that I actually wanted to show
one thing that's super convenient at
least in the iPhone and I I'm not
familiar enough with Android to know how
that works but because every lesson with
audio that I complete gets added to my
playlist every time I do anything out in
the yard whatever going going for a run
and I want to listen to my Japanese I
just tap and hold the link app icon and
then I get a variety of options here one
of which is the playlist option which
immediately opens my playlist it's just
and and starts playing which is super
convenient because it takes seconds to
literally get my listening going every
time so whenever I'm listening that's
that's the path I take you'll see in my
playlist that where Steve prefers to do
to play courses pretty much this is
every lesson in Japanese that I've done
over the last I'll call it six months at
least lessons with audio obviously so
there's a mixed bag of all the many
stories a variety of our podcasts
there's some videos from YouTube there's
a couple chapters of Harry Potter anyway
there's a variety of stuff in here
so that whenever I play it I just plays
whatever I have it on shuffle and
continuous play so I think that all
right just think that's a super
convenient so I just wanted to show that
and then I guess the last thing I wanted
to show is how to import how to import
from the from the browser which is not
always clear to people let's see if we
can find a Japanese this might find a
Japanese article we'll just take any one
of these and so once I have an article
up to import it from you're on your
mobile app you get to share a coupon and
here I don't seem to have the link ones
showing right now but if I don't have it
then I have to go to more to find it and
then
it automatically pulls this information
then I can import that lesson
aside from dot we wait for that to
report taking a while what I thought I
might do is show you a sneak peek of our
new interface that that those of us a
few of us internally have been playing
around with for the last a few a little
while so you'll see here this is our new
Reader interface this is a sentence view
this would be your regular view so just
a little bit of a sneak peek at what's
coming just a bit of an updated sort of
flow and view be interesting to see what
people's thoughts are here any feedback
but we're very excited and hoping that
you know within within maybe a month at
least if not sooner we might be able to
get a beta user group together and so
we'll be asking for volunteers and CERN
and hopefully some of you will be
interested and help us test out not just
a new iOS app but the new web app and
the new Android app so at some point
we'll send out an email but obviously if
you're interested please let us know and
we'll add you to our list and let you
know as soon as the app is ready for for
beta testing
uh okay with that I'll pass it on to
Eric and hopefully you got your tech new
inside this one last time so just bear
with me one sec here
okay so on
their share screen share okay so can you
see my phone yeah yes okay great okay so
I want to show everyone a few things
that I've been doing on the link so just
a bit of background I have been using
links for a year and already a year and
three four months reading Japanese and
I've been reading every day mostly news
articles and a select few blog that I've
enjoyed the first thing I want to show
you is for those who enjoy music how you
can import music into link and I'm going
to do it using my Android device so let
me just quickly show you so this is a
user YouTube app and this is a song
right here so this is a Japanese song
obviously and if I just play it quickly
you're gonna see let me see if it pops
up so everything you import as you can
see there everything you import has to
have closed captioning and in this case
you can see the video has Japanese
closed caption so what I do is I click
in the middle share and then I click on
import as a lesson I make sure the
language is Japanese and I hit import
I'm not going to do that now because
I've already done it but once I import
the lesson it's going to look something
like this in link so as you can see this
is my mobile device and this is the
j-pop course I've created and I've
imported many songs and system of course
and here are all the songs and the song
I just showed you on YouTube is right
here at the bottom mando Grasso Grosso
and ahead but this is a song so there
you go this is the lyrics and you also
get the audio so as you can see you're
not just listening to the song as you go
you are also looking at the vocabulary
how it's being used understanding the
structure of how songs and grammar are
and so with length I can just look up a
word and I can go to the next page and I
can look up the words I do not know and
once again I can click on the bottom
left corner there the play button and I
have the song also what's really really
cool about link just in case though you
don't know if you look at the top under
the picture you see the I guess the
speaker icon if you press that speaker
icon it will play the audio related to
the sentence so let's say I'm reading
this sentence right here and I don't
know really the pronunciation or how it
flows I can just press that speaker icon
and it will take the timestamp and that
sentence will play super useful
and just go through this song and then
once you're done that or once I'm done
that I have as you can see tons of other
songs secondly I want to show you as
Mark pointed out playlist so you can
create your own playlist with link and
it's perfect because it acts like a
playlist if you were to create a
playlist of songs as well so to do that
I can just click the three dots that you
can see on the right there there's three
dots click that
add to playlist BAM go back click on my
playlist and there it is and I can just
do this for all the songs all the
courses and as I'm walking or going
outside I can just hit play and I can do
continuous play shuffle which is really
great so that's just the music aspect of
my Japanese material and I am viewing
this in course view as you can see at
the top left there if I click lesson
you'll see the lessons but I'm just
going to go back to course view so it's
a little bit more organized
so that's j-pop what's really good if
you use link YouTube has a lot of music
with the closed captioning you might
have to do a little bit of searching but
usually once you find a channel there'll
be other videos with the closed
captionings as well and I scroll down
here this is another youtuber Miku real
Japanese she puts her own transcripts
and closed captions in her videos which
are super helpful so I have all this
material here recently I've been reading
this episode and it's been extremely
helpful and if I go down a bit my
conversation reports from my tutors
another YouTube channel MacGuffin which
is a good Japanese channel for learning
basic or everyday conversation
matcha blog link mini-stories which is
perfect for beginners and okay this is
really cool so this is Akita and it's
for those who don't know it's one of the
most popular anime movies ever and there
are resources online that have anime
streaming that have the subtitles the
Japanese subtitles so you can actually
import that into link when I open this
so this is a movie so you're going to
see that link splits up the movie into
in this case four different lessons
because it's
our movie so now I have the entire movie
in link and I can listen to the audio I
can go through the vocabulary and this
is like yeah this is really long but as
you can see you can do this with some
movies anime TV shows and whatnot super
helpful and it's what's great is
everything's organized as you can see I
even put my own little picture there so
I just have it looks a little nicer once
again more anime pseudo kuma cafe soggy
drop YouTube youtubers here and NHK easy
news and we have those Steve's book the
linguist in Japanese so once again I can
go through that entire book in Japanese
and as you've mentioned you can deceive
based on the last two minutes how much
content I have I have have more content
in this little polite little phone and
then I would ever have anywhere else I
mean I'm probably never going to finish
all reading all this but it's just there
for me to check out and another thing
I'd like to show is you can see the play
course audio which is at the top you
just click that
there you go see as you can see it's
loading out
and as it loads I can just press play
and the whole entire course will be
playing super helpful I've been using my
phone more and more because I've been
going out if I'm going for a stroll
taking my dog on a walk
so yeah that's uh that's what I wanted
to show you guys in the Android app and
I must have I don't know I must have
thousands of hours of material already
on link as you can see here and that's
our that's all I wanted to show once
again to import let me just quickly show
you on YouTube you just click the share
button and you just hit link the link
button and you're good to go so that's
it that's uh what I've been doing and
let me let me get back into stop sharing
here so that's what I've been doing with
my studies for the last little while and
yeah it helps a lot because now I can
read manga obviously the executor movie
I showed you that would probably be my
ultimate goal is going through that it
just takes lots of time because um you
just have to get used to the vocabulary
and yes it and in my opinion you have to
get vocabulary from every source all
kinds of sources like news anime
youtubers I just like that because I
don't want to get stuck with one set of
vocabulary so yeah that's kind of my
method for learning like learning
Japanese only great oh thanks thanks for
sharing and I think hopefully you did a
great job painting your room and
painting that lamp behind you yeah yeah
I know it's one of the cool features of
when you're staying at home you can do
it anything you want yeah you've got a
lot of time I guess for painting yeah
exactly
I could put a Japanese I can make it a
Japanese background next time but
anyways
and uh hopefully I mean I think people
hopefully learned a few things about
mobile today I think there's a few
questions here somebody's asking about
putting having two parts of a Polish
lesson on the same playlist I mean that
all your lessons get out into a playlist
so if you want specific parts from the
same playlist or same story course I
think you should do what Steve was
suggesting which is to play that course
if you when you import a long episode of
something and and make splits it into
two parts it's part of the same course
so if you open that course and play that
course you'll get people get the parts
of that course played consecutively one
thing to be I'm just gonna say if you
are importing things that you want to be
in the same course please be out you
know make sure that you put it in the
same course cuz you just go import like
the easiest thing is to go to edit if
you've got say three lessons in a course
edit the lesson and add it from there
then you know that it's talking into the
same course but if you happen to use
import the import icon and you want it
to go to a particular spot make sure you
select that course then it'll all be in
that course and if you go listen to
course audio you'll hear all the lessons
that are in there of course so
definitely something to get familiar
with if you want to have a specific
playlist if you will because otherwise
the general playlist is just there is
only one and all your lessons end up
there so if you want a lesson too
specific to specific sets of lessons you
can either listen to in a course or you
can create a fake course and use that as
a special type of playlist okay any
questions on YouTube that to anyone this
scene there there's a couple of
questions here mark that I see one was
anyone know why I can't import
traditional Chinese characters from
Netflix I have no idea I've never tried
it does anyone know mark
that's not possible that should be
possible there was an issue before there
are sometimes issues with certain
languages on Netflix and you just have
to report those issues and and we'll so
we can get them fixed because we are
unable to test every single language
because sometimes they're labeled
slightly differently and and so we can't
test every show so if you come across a
UH if you're trying to import a show and
the subtitles are shown on Netflix
they're in the list of subtitle
languages but they don't seem to be
importing let us know and and will then
be able to go in check into that but we
did have a problem with traditional
Chinese characters but that should be
fixed now there is a question as well on
link 5.0 and I think you've covered it
all I can say is I can't wait because
I've sampled bits and pieces of it you
know we don't want to get ahead of
ourselves though and another question
was how to import Kindle e-books into
link personally I found that I used to
be able to do that I would buy the ePub
from on my my computer and I could then
use calibre to convert it into a format
that I could import into link and that
seems to no longer be possible I don't
know if anyone else has any wisdom to
shed on that yeah I don't I have to have
the same experience I think Eric maybe
looked into it previously and there was
some way of getting an older version of
the Kindle app for your caliber that I
have an older version will will will do
the newer version doesn't I don't know
why that's something I read online
anyway but I haven't actually tried to
install the older version do it yeah
yeah I think they make it Kindle
particularly makes it difficult I think
the last time we looked at the one of
the issues was kindled hides where it
stores the Kindle files on your computer
which once you can find them then I
think it may still be possible to remove
the DRM although
for Japanese books anyway it's quite a
what make it difficult which is very
annoying one of the things we talked
about here and hopefully we get to one
day is where we can have deals with
publishers so that we can publish ebooks
integrated with link via link users pay
for that of course even if the audiobook
is is a separate purchase not necessary
I mean ideally it's all integrated that
might be more difficult and those are
things amongst the many sort of
eventually we would like to be able to
do list and one of them is to integrate
with the very good e-books and
audiobooks in various languages that are
out there so one step at a time
hopefully we get there one day right any
other questions just take a quick look
at
one thing I should add mark is it's
amazing this explosion of mobile
computing and the percentage of people
who access the internet via their you
know smartphone and also the number of
the percentage of people who study their
languages with link on their smartphone
I think I'm unique in that I like my
iPad I guess some people like doing it
on the on the web with their computer
but I think the majority now are using
their iPhone which is absolutely it's
extraordinary
so that if we look at a traditional
language class you're in a classroom
with a teacher who is giving you in in
sort of dribs and drabs wisdom about the
language here's a you know how you could
you know conjugate verbs and you're
depending on the teacher to give you
everything and you're sitting in a
classroom and then you half an hour or
an hour to get home and now we have
everything essentially at our fingertips
through mobile language learning it's to
my mind is revolutionary I never cease
to wonder just how convenient language
learning has become you know great
there's a question here
asking where we live in the USA all of
us are actually not in the USA we're all
in Vancouver I mean because they have no
cases I want to be fair Doreen
I think what we're seeing in so far as
kovat is that East generally speaking
has been hit harder than the West no
Vancouver like British Columbia Alberta
has relatively low death count you know
fewer cases but California has done
relatively well you know Washington had
that original outbreak but they've been
able to control that and so whereas
moved to Ontario and Quebec if you moved
to you know New York New York New Jersey
you know Massachusetts so I don't
understand why but it certainly seems
that the East has been hit much harder
than the West yeah Montreal is just bad
but so is Boston so is Boston so
everything in the East I think it's
because it came in from Europe and while
you know is from
China and we're gonna stop anyone coming
from China I mean Vancouver has a huge
Chinese and Iranian population we had
lots of people coming in from China and
Iran we got very few cases whereas I
think people coming in in the case of
Quebec coming in from France and even
more so actually coming up from the US
in fact the US has been the largest
factor in those cases but it's not
didn't originate in the u.s. it came
from Europe to the East Coast and then
spread and I think that's been the
pattern that doesn't mean we won't get
hit later on during your vitamin D zinc
whatever it takes
yeah we have somebody asking I want to
learn German how how do I link words
with their deep dose it's necessary to
learn the word with this gender first of
all in terms of linking words with the
gender I mean if you want to do that
you're free to do that just link the two
words together just like creating any
other phrase obviously that the the the
initially it it's just the main that the
word that's blue so you can create a
link for the word or you can select on
your device whether you're on the
computer or your mobile device select
the two words together and save them and
learn them that way you can label you
can you can tag words with with their
with their DDoS if you want if it's if
you want to review that way yeah I think
our belief is that over time if you see
those words enough you'll just start to
slowly remember which words are there or
D or das but if you if you want to
really focus on it you can save them as
phrases I don't know if Steve you have
thoughts on that well yeah I think this
gender obviously this there's two issues
here one is gender one is case and these
are things that come up come up in
obviously in Romance languages come up
in in Russian or Slavic languages I
think you obviously have to save the
article with the now
and you can tag them for specific gender
you can tag them for a specific case
review them and you know in a
concentrated format but ultimately as
you get used to hearing you know the
skint that the kid is the skin or or
whatever and then even in longer phrases
where in them or in there so the and yet
you will continue to have trouble with
it there is no way I find that that
something that is doesn't exist in your
own language it's gonna be difficult and
with enough listening and enough paying
attention and when you hear it say and I
do this in many stories I hear certain
structures certain phrases that that I
want to kind of ingrain in my brain so
that without having to think is this the
you know feminine masculine neuter
dative genitive it's impossible to do
that while you're speaking so you just
have to bombard the brain with so much
content and try to pay attention and in
the hope that your percentage accuracy
will increase from fifty to sixty to
seventy and may never quite be a hundred
until you have a lot of exposure a lot
of opportunity to speak and so forth the
song it's an ongoing struggle
Martin Auden is saying he imported epub
and it worked great a day go there's no
problem importing epubs I mean our M
file import function works great but the
problem is that books Kindle e-books
most ebooks that you buy have DRM
digital rights management I guess which
prevents those files from being imported
into links so you have to remove the DRM
which you can do normally by doing a
google search for whatever type of file
you're trying to remove the DRM from and
then once you've done that you can
import the epub work and if it's in a
different form not converted into an
ePub or text or PDF file so you can
import it into links so that the file
import works just fine but the problem
is ebooks that are protected someone
here with
saying they have a way in the comments
of importing from Kindle something to do
with a Google search I don't fully
understand that but maybe something we
can we can explore but it sounds like
more of a copy-paste type method ideally
we when importing e-books you can take
the whole e-book file and import it at
once so that you can and have that book
for the next month or however long any
other questions there is it possible in
a link reader to have a loop play
repetition when you're in a single when
you're in single sentence mode that's
something in our in our wish list so it
may not be there initially but it's
something that we're aware of and hope
to have in the long run
you
somebody's asking me how my Arabic is
hello mark up yeah sorry you had a
question there first I just see some
Christian saying I import Kindle e-books
in the link on a regular basis you can
download them in Kindle Cloud Reader and
then use a tool called epub or KCR
converter to remove the DRM yeah I think
I've tried doing that the the trickiest
part lately has been finding the Kindle
books but I'm sure there's information a
lot of time is just doing a goofy we
could confirm that and put it on the
forum in some way because people are
often asking that question
let's go up a lot for sure yeah just see
a question here about how my Arabic is
mm-hmm
so Arabic is not the easiest language to
learn it takes a while to get used to
the writing system but I'm getting
better and I'm enjoying it and I focused
on standard Arabic for the longest time
and then I decided that I would try to
learn Levantine Arabic we have the many
stories in Levantine Arabic we have some
other content in Levantine Arabic so I
have been listening to Levantine Arabic
I had my first tutor session in
Lovington Arabic part of my motivation
was that the podcast that I listened to
that are supposed to be in standard
Arabic if they get somebody on there
from Lebanon or Syria he starts using a
lot of Levantine Arabic words mixed in
with his he thinks he's speaking
Standard Arabic but it's like 30 40 %
Levantine so in order to understand what
was going on I decided I would get used
to Levantine Arabic and then my wife
started watching this Egyptian Arabic
series on Netflix so and I've been
watching it the last couple of nights
and I can't really understand what's
going on so today I'm gonna spend the
day listening to Egyptian Arabic content
on link in the hope that tonight I will
understand more so my Arabic is
meandering all over the place but I'm
enjoying it tremendously we have someone
asking about keyboard shortcuts when
they switch their keyboard language from
English to Korean the keyboard shortcuts
changed
is it possible the same shortcuts well I
don't know I don't know that's the first
time you ever heard that any issues like
that it's always good to email us so
that we're at least aware that's just
never really occurred to us anyway I'll
make a note and we'll look into it and
see what mark another question I see
here
yeah who started learning European
Spanish from the link many stories but
the European Spanish only goes to 20
should I continue with the Latino
Spanish where there are 60 stories all
right definitely you should continue
with the Latino Spanish there is going
to be essentially no difference in the
vocabulary between the European Spanish
and the Latino Spanish the only place
where there are differences is gonna be
in the slangy Street version of the
language where you'll have more local
variation even within South America but
in terms of the many stories there's
going to be essentially no difference
you need to learn all those words and
yeah listen listen to the first 20
stories in European Spanish more often
to get a better sense of that flavor so
you can go back to those but by all
means go through the 60 I will check
with Zoran as to where we stand on the
European Spanish many stories from 21 to
60 and you know in the longer run you'll
end up listening to so much content in
whichever form of the language you want
that you can start you know imitating
the form of the language that you want
to use but the vocabulary is the same
the pronunciation in Spanish doesn't
vary very much it's not like Portuguese
where there's a big difference so
definitely I I would I would do both not
only with many stories in the case of
Spanish I would use whatever content I'm
interested in regardless of the of the
source and you'll very quickly start to
identify whether it's syrupy in Spanish
or Spanish from South America but I
think even with regard to Portuguese
where they yeah they sound different but
the written form is it not more or less
the same it's very much the same in in
my Portuguese I listen to both and you
got to get used to both because after
all you might hear someone from Portugal
or someone from Brazil so
but in terms of when you speak you wanna
focus in on one so so you want to listen
to more like I I had to have a chat with
Gabriel from Brazil the other day and
and I find that my Portuguese is kind of
in between Spanish European and
Brazilian and you kind of have to focus
on one so I went to all global which is
a newspaper in San Paulo and I got a
whole really good podcast so I was
listening to that
for much the day so you focus in on the
one you want to be able to imitate but
the vocabulary again there's very little
difference written between Portuguese
and like Portugal and and Brazil it's
the same language obviously as Steve are
you still studying polish I'm learning
and would love to see a video on it
Thanks you know I can't maintain all the
languages that I've ever learned polish
is one of those that I would have to
refresh it I haven't been doing anything
in Polish for quite a while but I think
if I I would what I do is I go back to
my mini stories that's like my gym
that's where I work on my core and if I
spent if I spent a day listening my mini
stories I could get my polish back up to
her where I was and and then I would
listen to some of these audiobooks that
I have in Polish I'd go back to what I
what I did the last time and I think
within a week I'd be ahead of where I
was before but right now it would be
difficult now we'll leave for Nancy
support and help users who go out of
their way to procure native speakers to
write and read and record podcast and
spend money on adding mark I mean this
is a in principle if it's really good
stuff I think we might yeah potentially
but right now anyone who creates content
and shares it if the content is popular
they do earn a small amount of they earn
points so it you know obviously big
contributors can actually earn
significant numbers of points in terms
of whether we and we don't tend to
generate that much of our own content
whether ourselves or content that we pay
for so we're happy to talk to people and
if it seems like it's something that a
lot of our users are gonna benefit from
we we would we would look at it but
we rely on our members to create content
and share it yeah I think we'd have to
look at it on a case-by-case basis if
it's really good and and if it's really
good and it's a language that I'm
learning I'd be willing to pay for it
and then share it so in the case of
Persian arraign we have this wonderful
content on the history of Iran I'm
paying for it it's going up there so
it's gotta be on a case man that's I'm
just joking just because I'm interested
but if it's something that's truly
outstanding for our link members
certainly we would look at it there's a
question here can I import YouTube
videos on the mobile app I think you saw
Eric do that so you may want to rewatch
the presentation to look for that dis
demonstration there's also a video
Steve's channel or the link channel I
guess I should there's a whole guide on
importing if you go to link YouTube
channel and you search how to import
there's a there's a lot of guides on the
link YouTube channel
ok there's a few questions and
Portuguese which I can't really read
looks like maybe Latvian or Lithuanian
again Oh Steve your your microphones
muted yeah can you put those in the
slack marketing thing or were could I
have a look at the Portuguese questions
there in YouTube here alright so how do
I access the YouTube I gotta mmm okay
saying that in with the internet there's
so much information there that sometimes
we feel lost wouldn't be better to limit
to limit ourselves to less technology I
mean this is the problem nowadays is
that it's easy to be distracted the
Twitter is there you know and you've
just gotta focus on it's not a matter so
much it's not so much a matter of sort
of limiting the technology but it's a
matter of staying focused so it's harder
we have more opportunities and therefore
more opportunities to get distracted and
you just have to discipline yourself I
don't think there's any easy answers
there's a guy asking about Japanese
accents and whether they can be quite
difficult for English speakers to
understand Japanese accents
I guess Japanese people speaking English
or Japanese people speaking English or
regional versions of Japanese no
Japanese people speak English is it
difficult to understand Japanese people
speaking English because of their accent
I think you can't make those kinds of
generalizations is it difficult to speak
into under is it difficult for Japanese
people to understand English speakers
speaking Japanese it depends some speak
better than others I don't think there's
a simple generalized answer to that and
I guess a lot of the time people think
it's an accent problem but a lot of the
time it's a word usage problem you know
we often say that if you use natural
phrasing even with a strong accent
you're perfectly comprehensible whereas
a lot of the time when people blame
their accent in fact it's not the accent
it's the way they use words that people
are having trouble understanding do we
have Spanish language videos Oryx help
about how to use the site because
there's a person asking here and there
are explanations on how to use a site in
Spanish there's definitely some help
available in Spanish obviously the
majority of the help is or depending on
the language some more or less may be
translated so
videos are probably all in English but
we do have help questions that are
translated it just depends on what
you're looking at but if you go to the
help page and your interface is in
Spanish most of those questions should
be translated I'm not aware if we have
we probably do have some Spanish help
videos I would have to look into it I'm
not a hundred percent sure tenemos
algunas infirmity honest excreta
pero video no there are this place the
baby on the link palma so tambien affair
videos in in distinct us in distinctive
idiomas and quantization who says to the
padilla how many hours you study
everyday I tend to get in 45 minutes to
an hour of listening at least another
half hour at least of linking on my iPad
any chance of allowing the importer to
hit self hosted content currently seems
to rely on certain services about a
generic URL I'm not a hundred percent
sure I understand the question I mean
the the importer certainly works on most
news sites most blog sites in order to
work with YouTube or anime sites or
Netflix we've had to customize how it
imports if you have generic URLs with
mp4 mp3 files yeah again that sounds
like custom application but if you have
examples and you'd like something added
please email us and we'll look at it and
if it makes sense and it's something
that we think a lot of others in our
community would benefit from then it's
something that we would do if it's
something that's specific to you as a
user and nobody else is likely to need
that or a few people are then we're
unlikely to do it
what iPad models do you guys use I'm
thinking about buying myself an iPad
because the link Android has many
limitations and bugs first of all yeah
the the Android app unfortunately does
tend to lag the iPhone app in terms of
speed of development we're trying to
improve that but and I think in terms of
bugs hopefully the Android app has
resolved a lot of the issues recently
with their last release we are hoping
that the new Android version will come
out at a similar time to the iOS version
and web versions but in terms of which
iPads I mean I have a regular iPad I
don't know probably the most recent sort
of regular or maybe a year ago this
version of the regular iPad and it it
works well no complaints there I don't
know what version Steve uses but any
iPad will work fine
mine is fairly recent I think any iPad
this very recent I mean especially
because the new new app will only work
on iOS 13 and above or something so
older devices won't be able to run the
new version of link by the way mark yeah
question in Latin Lithuanian or
whichever was do you speak and the
answer do you speak Lithuanian the
answer is no okay I'll translate okay
mark here's another question
QA the import of e-books in ebooks and
ePub format works just fine but in PDF
format and it doesn't keep the new lines
also it is not possible to add audio to
the ebooks if it is split in more than
one file how can we overcome this yeah
a few different questions there the the
PDF question I suppose that could happen
and again if the if it's happening
please report it so that we can
troubleshoot and try to try to fix the
issue the issue of long text being split
and therefore requiring the audio file
to be split is one that can be a bit
tricky in a lot of languages where we
have the ability to compare the audio
with text I think we we do sometimes
enable the audio file to be split as
well but we need it's a bit of a
complicated answer but there's a time
stamping capability when we split
lessons and so sometimes we do get the
audio split but it very much depends on
the language because we don't have that
capability in all languages so if you
have specific questions about specific
imports you'd have to email us and we'd
have to look at it but again those are
things that we're aware of and over time
we hope to come up with solutions that
will make make it easier I mean anything
we we're always looking at things that
we can do to make importing easier and
more effective and more efficient and
and especially things like that where
you know a lot of people would benefit
from from from an improvement like that
so we understand the issue and that's in
our wish list long term
oh I see the question related to video
is if users want to store the videos on
on their own host the videos themselves
but then import them into link I mean
we've never again looked at that but the
all suggestions are good I think best
this is kind of a tough place for
suggestions because these questions are
kind of zipping by if you have
improvements suggestions for
improvements or new features or
optimizations the best place is probably
to put them on the forum or to send
emails to support and we start to
collect that kind of feedback and see
which requests come up repeatedly and
and start as we plan improvements but it
but it with regard to you know a system
being smart enough to import mp3 and
subtitles and yeah all of that stuff
we're continuing to try and make it
better all the time I would say also
with regard to that PDF question if the
PDF is not working and you have caliber
and can change it into another format
and try that instead that's certainly
something you can do in the meantime
um someone is asking if there is no iOS
app yet yeah yes there is an iOS app
we're talking about a new version of the
app which will be coming out hopefully
within the next few months
someone says thank you I've been using
duolingo and it's time to lose those
training wheels and move to a real app
is this a good step up anyone if you
want to learn your language yes it's a
good step up yeah I think if you've if
you've graduated from duolingo and
you're ready for more I think even even
as a beginner you can use Lync but
you'll certainly benefit from from using
Lync and driving your comprehension and
vocabulary growth unless anyone else has
anything to say I think we probably
covered it here so we'll we'll let you
go thanks very much everyone for joining
us and I look forward to all your
suggestions any time in the forum or our
support ok thanks everyone stay safe bye
bye